I am Chloe Bennet and I play he in
abominable what are you supposed to be a
famous person uh I have six brothers and
I was like we could watch princess
movies no no but justice ugh so it was
very much video games and sports growing
up and so I never connected with
princesses on screen Yi being this
feisty young Chinese girl who was
ambitious and confident what are you
gonna do take him all the way back to
Mount Everest
maybe I am I never grew up seeing that
on camera
the idea that ye as a character will
inspire young girls to feel okay with
themselves is really exciting animation
takes a lot more imagination because
you're literally not in front of
anything you can do magic I really felt
like a kid doing it you can do magic I
didn't watch a lot of TV growing up I
was always playing pretend and making my
brothers dress up as characters and
playing around in the alley in the south
side of Chicago and jumping out of
dumpsters and doing make-believe things
just kind of felt like that again but on
like a much more professional exciting
scale it's those guys from the city
[Music]